[Applause]
with Alejandro Fernández an icon of
Mexican music welcome to Las Vegas
in Spanish thank you very much
a pleasure thank you very much for your
time let's start by talking about the announcement
that you are
doing something very special to celebrate the national
holidays here in salsa
and we are  returning from the usa in this
very important month for all mexicans
the tour is called love and homeland we are going to
do few presentations we are going to do
six dates and i am over 15 years old i
think about 20 years old natalia i
don't know since i started
to sing one, they started looking for it,
I started in places
in very small theaters and then every
year we go and we grow, the capacity is increased by
presenting the best arenas and
well right now we are presenting it in
the most important one that is understood and just
to make it clear, nothing else in  September 15 and
17 in Las Vegas will be
the only luck that will be
accompanying my son.
What would your son care about what your father
encouraged?  in you when I
wanted to dedicate myself to the career of products and
life, his eyes and he told me I want I want
it to be very clear that you will never
move for economic
reasons and you always go up on a stage that is
100% for you and that  the only thing that moves you
is the love of singing and
[Applause]
[Music]